nem botar todos nós pretendemos falar
sobre este título que vocês vêem nesta
produção do teclado andamento do dia' da
que foi uma simples que nós encontramos
em português um verso num atleta por ele
chamado jorge de sena e precisamente
fala o neste verso sobre é copti chi ou
a colaboração entre piano e percussão e
suas flores seu pênis negócio
o sinistro portanto não vai falar foi o
tema que foi surgir como todo o estado
empresta apresentação a partir de néné e
individualidade e mas também somos
milhões em vídeos de partilharmos com o
nosso próximo e com os nossos as pessoas
que habitam e convivem conosco que
diariamente
portanto competition combina as palavras
cooperação e competição e ver o que é
melhor para concretizar e congregar esse
conceito do que música é uma partilha a
especificar musical com os outros
músicos
vocês vão ver em seguida nós só vamos
falar um bocadinho depois vamos tentar
eo no voto cara senão partilharmos em
indução e expressividade outro músico
por isso consideramos que é uma
homenagem ao conceito competition
copti chan é é como viajar explicou tem
uma aplicabilidade muito grande à nossa
área a música é e em santos todos
pensarmos é porque desde o melhor ano
como é porque cada músico não sendo uma
empresa não sendo o vinho na entidade
científica por natureza é tem é no seu
melhor naquilo no seu produto é sua
individualidade estética nas suas
crenças e expectativas e portanto é é um
ser também para outros músicos altamente
competitivo que quando partilhamos quem
essas coisas e vendendo nós vamos ter é
uma peça de um compositor grego
infelizmente a testa acaba com os copos
é é uma peça inspirada num canto
santino no mínimo diante do século 18 é
e nós vamos poder perceber ao longo da
peça aqui inspiração é de facto muito
grande nesse ano e as situações claras e
podem inclusivamente ao chegar ao fim da
peça o versa
é tudo além da décima distribuído entre
o piano e vibrafone
como já falei no início é em música e
sobre a música arte universal por
influência para lá da barreira da língua
que se constrói sobre o instante
precisamente e tem ainda como objetivo
incentivar a implementação da bits a
audição de música ao vivo isso também é
a mensagem que gostaríamos de passar
aqui hoje
o que é certo é que estudos realizados
sobre esta questão da música ao vivo da
freqüência dos espetáculos do gênero
demonstrado que em todos os
tipos de música um aumento do público
desde o ano 2000
além disso consideramos que estas
apresentações musicais fomentam a
autonomia ea responsabilidade tanto no
que diz respeito à organização como a
interpretação musical portanto as
apresentações musicais públicas rafael
mais importante é uma arte que é para
ser mostrada com um em 2014 é e fazem
também concluir neste do mundial da copa
e também um segmento que é o público
efetivamente até para ser mostrada evita
a exibição é isso que vamos tentar fazer
que os trabalhos
segundo um estudo realizado por conta e
teixeira em 2011
acerca dos festivais de música de verão
em portugal este tipo de eventos são
frequentados maioritariamente por
estudantes da área artística
isso é uma constatação algo
surpreendente nas muito em aix oura e e
e significativa pensando em nós
portanto a participação em festivais de
música prende se não só com as
experiências diferentes aventura de
surpresa mas também conhecimento a nível
intelectual e visa intensificar as
relações familiares e colaborativas
na música conseguimos de confluência de
todas as vertentes da nossa
personalidade com ser tanto e as
dissonâncias do mundo procurando no
contacto vivo com a tecla do piano com
os instrumentos uma extensão das
possibilidades do nosso corpo
eu quero sempre como se fosse a primeira
vez
e é isso que vamos fazer aqui agora
ah
hum
o
ah
a rã
a amm
o
o gol
ah
ah ah ah ah ah ah
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
ah